if we can get him to drive to
Connecticut
dude no dude no dude I was just Listen
whoa one God I don't even I don't even
know how to explain this
um uh Dwight asked me to be in an
alliance and then um
um we were we've just been messing with
him uh because of the whole Alliance
thing
um it's just office pranks that's stupid
it's just office pranks Albert
hey uh I uh you know heard there's a
rumor going around about you used to
have a crush on Pam and oh no no no no
no it's it's cool because I know you're
a good guy and I know that that Crush
ended a long time ago so you know
all right cool right
yeah nope yeah definitely you know I'm
it's great with me because we're glad
she has a friend at work she can get
through the day with Donald you know
when she gets home yeah I like talking
to her too so uh we're cool right yes
yeah all right yeah all right cool man
sweet sorry babe I'm just beat it's okay
I'll see you at home okay hey don't try
to lose too much money all right I guess
you still want to want a honeymoon
hey Harper keep an eye on her all right
okay we'll do
hey how's it going good especially after
I took all your money in poker
hey uh
do you want to do that now we can go
inside
feeling kind of good tonight
I was just um
I'm in love with you what
I'm really sorry if that's weird for you
to hear but I need you to
hear it
probably not in good timing I know that
I just what are you doing
what do you expect me to say to that
well
I am
I
I
can't
you have no idea don't do that
what your friendship needs to be
don't do that
I want to be more than that
oh my gosh
I just got an email from Andy that means
they hit land what up shorty we got in
last night sold the boat went out got
drunk
saw Life of Pi got super depressed and
introspective
gonna hang out here a while
maybe a couple of weeks
figure this whole life thing out
maybe see Hobbit
weights
hey everything okay
so what comes next
right
um
okay
so he says uh
after we call the police they'll waste
hours trying to negotiate so just watch
the movie that makes much more sense or
we can just sit and talk though no no
more talking it's movie time
think Andy would ever jump off an
exploding building to I do a hose for me
yeah
definitely
what oh no come here hey hey
I'm still Angie's girlfriend
oh yeah of course I know
but you can leave your arm
you dance Wars forever
and then oh wait no you go did I is that
you you go first and then it's no you go
okay all right no I did it all right
okay
all right oh God Andy has just started
to be nice to me and now I've sent his
girlfriend into the arms of a younger
man and I see seed him on every
incriminating memo Pete and Aaron don't
hold back our social media presence
should be hot hot go at it vigorously I
did everything but unzip their pants for
them
are you okay
I couldn't do it
oh
I'm sorry
oh you don't have to apologize
I just
want you to be happy okay
we're breaking up
honey why is Daryl here he works in the
warehouse I invited him it's not a party
Daryl back downstairs this is the
information you need there's information
here yeah you're right I don't need this
[Music]
okay
it's like she only wants to hook up when
Ryan comes around
it's gotten to the point where I get
excited every time I see that little
dude walk through the door
um
this can't happen again this has to
happen again Daryl can't happen again
look at me
do you want me to do more push-ups yeah
okay you have to break up with their own
I already typed out a text message for
you
all you have to do is press send
I don't know I mean it's well written
and all
it has to be done
press send together
oh my God he's gonna kill us I'd like to
see him try
oh
he says it's cool
I said it's cool that's all you wrote
that's all I wrote can I see it
didn't you two date for like a long time
this is like a very
[Music]
good
Angela
will you do me the honor
of giving me your tiny hand
in marriage
okay
into the mic sweetie I said okay she
said yes
and The Crowd Goes whoa
whoa hey
so since Maury or lady has such
particular impossible to perceive taste
I have made non-refundable deposits at
four totally different wedding locales
hot air balloons over Napa Valley world
famous Walt Disney's Epcot Center scuba
diving wedding in The Bahamas and the
Wilkes-Barre Marriott Ballroom sea
dangerous tacky sharks haunted no
I have a nice comforter and several cozy
pillows I usually read a chapter of a
book and it lights out by 8 30. that's
how I sleep at night
another day all righty but she'll be
fine I am off have a good meeting thank
you
kick Wallace's ass okay I will
Dwayne and Angela are having an affair
so I can't hear you through the glass
Dwight and Angela are having an affair
they've been sleeping together for some
time
that was the news
I wanted to let you know what all right
see you later
ah are you serious yeah
[Music]
Dwight
Andy
it's over
oh good she broke up with you no
it's over between you two ah no way
I am not giving up you have to no I
don't
she doesn't love you she's marrying me
well I don't know about that because she
certainly seems to enjoy making love
making with me Angela Bernard will never
be her name it will be her name and you
will have to call her that I don't think
so hey guys why don't we uh just cool
off a bit I'm telling you to back down
and I'm telling you that I will never
back down then I'll make you oh really
how are you gonna do that through the
use of force that is very general and
does not scare me in the slightest I
will fight you nope okay fine good a
duel the winner gets Angela bye bye this
is nuts Dwight are your legs broken no
my right one's falling asleep a little
bit Danny you all right go away tuna I'm
winning this yeah back off this isn't
your fight oh how much is this gonna
cost oh what trust fund will take care
of that what did you say I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you
what you stupid idiot you're like a bit
you're like a Sasquatch
sasquatches are the strongest animal on
the planet so fine call me a Sasquatch